this podcast is Now supported by patreon
if you like the show and you want to
help us in our goal of making some more
creative stuff alongside it you can help
out by going to patreon.com char Alonzo
we are recording so we're recording also
Troy I think it's just busy I don't
actually know where he is this week
but somewhere in the world he working
somewhere he might be a sheer off
somewhere it might be a sleep yeah it
might be night time wherever he is I
have no idea I've made a mystery quite a
traveler I'm pretty sure he's uh yeah
pretty sure he's in Europe uh and it's
you know appreciably evening but I don't
actually remember it's
it could be right here it's as close to
tabs as I keep on him he could be behind
any of us
a mo-cap suited arm comes out and
reaches towards me here we go cool we
should do that at some point we should
have we should have thank you we should
have Troy like come uh uh visit me at
some point and just kind of pop up in
the call and freak everyone out that'd
be great Cameo
yeah that's cool we should all we should
all do a cameo at some point if yeah if
we can all show up in each other's
backgrounds at some point I like the
idea of that that's great well in La
quite a bit that's true you are now I
can actually talk about why yeah MIT on
camera that I'm in La so that's good
proving that you're in L.A
that thread of the person like breaking
down our statistics
um from the show where they had the it
like culminated in their Awards and the
best Cameo went to Rahul it's amazing
how insanely disturbing it looks as a
screen capture like as a still image of
just this kind of like a shadowy
silhouette don't refer to him as it it's
massively dismissive put that on screen
just to give that a shout out because
it's so cool
um it was so funny this is from Tyler
Flom on Twitter they watch this in
overall stats number of episodes
including 37.5 and 53.1
average episode length is an hour and
6.9 minutes longest is an hour and 57.5
minutes I wonder what that one was when
yeah who has time for that that was
clearly early in the pandemic when you
weren't like doing the meeting yeah
probably
um well you hadn't started your current
job I
for the first bunch of episodes of this
is that right yeah I started in 2020 so
there'd be more episodes where I've been
at SMS than not at this point
uh which is one of my stats is includes
mention of God of War 33 times 38 of
episodes on average
Mike Thomas Was Alone counter has to be
higher than that yeah Thomas Was Alone
didn't they put a journey mention
counter for me also he's gonna be quite
High uh you have a Jerry Goldsmith
mention 19 times
[Laughter]
17. I liked also there was one that that
mentioned how often I just mentioned
other composers in general and I was
like stories about other controls
bolsters 96 to 85 I think that reflects
positively on you that that gave me some
nerd street cred that I I joined this
profession because of a love of
that the craft and the art
and there and and I and I take pride in
that I haven't become jaded or whatever
about the the sort of lived realities of
being a pleasure that I still like
positive mention or a negative mention
that might just be complaining about
other comparisons I feel like you talk
about other composers more often than
you talk about yourself as a composer
and I feel like that is a very good sign
of not being jaded or letting the
industry get to you or whatever
um
58 58 episodes 50 of your episodes
um I didn't realize how much you did
this Mike is starts explanation with the
phrase what's interesting about that is
is an average of 1.51 times per episode
I didn't even know that you did that
what a boring [ __ ] I missed the
problem is any kind of statistical
analysis immediately proves how awful
humans are repetitive so Troy had one
like that too
it's interesting vomit during the
podcast
um includes mentioned at The Last of Us
is 73 episodes
Troy says by and large is 50 of episodes
on average
and then it has a note that says you can
tell in episode 57 and onward Troy is
trying not to say by and large large as
much before episode 57 he used the
phrase an 87.72 episodes
just for self-awareness
um yeah it's amazing I don't think
people should be exposed to this level
of analysis of themselves like this is
probably this is too much awareness
it is amazing though it was a very cool
thing to read to him I enjoyed the fact
that
my comment that
um all blonde women look the same look
the same to me got they removed the word
blonde if I recall correctly which just
reduced it to all women look the same to
me and I was like this is going to play
great on Twitter without any kind of
context yeah
um there's no famously charitable we may
have done it in the episode ourselves I
don't know it seems like something I
even remember but background
the uh the former Imaging lead of the
Cassini probe and one of our three
scientists from when we did our Science
Show Carolyn Porco
um who you know kind of randomly appears
in my Twitter like we follow each other
and interact periodically but it's
always very sporadic like it's
unpredictable when she'll kind of see
something and respond but of course that
was the one where she goes excuse me
Austin all women look the same uh and I
was like oh God how do I even how do I
even explain this in a tweet so I just
said there's a context let's just leave
it there let's jump on a cool let's do a
two-hour explanation right yeah it does
exist terrible choices uh it doesn't
necessarily make it any better but at
least there is a context oh well I think
it does I also don't really find that
offensive as as woman
yes uh as as resident woman you're fine
not offended it's all right that's how
it works you're uh the Council of women
has dismissed your offense reset the
clock
does it uh what is the fridge does it
Sparkle what's the South Park where
there is like a council of women like
it's the girls oh Sparkles yeah yeah it
is yeah they have like their kind of
where's Troy to correct me on the
Precision of my career I'm pretty sure
that that's it if it pleases and
sparkles I think if it pleases it
Sparkles I knew there were two yeah
perfect pleases and sparkles and then
they all replies genius yeah I love it
I'd like to reopen the minutes from last
meeting about which boy is the cutest
yeah unbelievable that episode is it
made I love it's like this conspiracy to
go shoe shopping and they're like
holding guns at each other on the roof
of the school [ __ ] hilarious I still
think that Wendy testabaga is one of the
best characters in anything ever I think
she's fantastic and also like the whole
show there's there's hardly a weak link
anywhere I think I think one of my
favorite bits that 20 years in still
doesn't get off
is that thing still going yeah no it is
it's still going um I don't like
Integrity that much I think it ran the
bit was too long
I think that it didn't benefit from the
kind of more uh serialized format which
was a new experiment for them
um I agree it it it wore for them it
wore thin but I still Marvel at the fact
that I think that they're one of the
only
creators broadly speaking like to put
all things in one bucket that that
uh generally speaking have not wavered
in quality decades in like like there's
always highs and lows and misses but
like you know whereas there's a general
consensus I would think that Simpsons
for example has been on like a long slow
kind of decline
um and that even if it has upticks
relative to where it was 25 years ago
just kind of doesn't compare
um I don't know that that's true for
them I think you're right you can still
this season have an episode that is like
absolutely brilliant that can rival the
best area
and how crazy is that like imagine doing
a thing day in day out for decades and
like maybe tomorrow will be your best
one like that's
almost unheard of especially with
something of the kind of grind that well
I think that's why because of the way
that they make it what's more amazing to
me is they haven't quit but I think
because of the way that they make that
show the you know weak turnaround or
whatever it is that they're
it would both be very difficult and they
are very advantaged by it
Simpsons I imagine has a lot of trouble
staying relevant I don't did the kids
watch The Simpsons these days well yeah
I mean those kinds of shows Family Guy
has a similar challenge where the
animation pipeline it's such more
relaxing this is mind-blowing for me
it's Family Guy still in there I don't
know Family Guy American Dad is still
going really American Dad's on like
season 19 or something
Fox got rid of American Dad and and it
went to uh American Dad went over to FX
I want to say season 18. holy [ __ ] but
they still do yeah they still do yeah
um and those uh those shows have much
longer animation pipelines so like
anything culturally relevant can be as
much as a year behind its moment in time
and South Park has always been
advantaged by the fact that their within
a week of current events and that's just
insane for an animated show what are
they um no I was just gonna say like
what are they how do they take vacations
you know they'll intermittently go and
write you know a book of Mormon or make
a team America or whatever like the fact
that they they fill that time or like
the [ __ ] the brilliant
um Stick of Truth yeah and uh I guess
the reality has to make sure that it's
more than Matt and Trey
um making those things which is the
thing that I you never think about which
obviously you should think about nothing
becomes that successful I think there's
a whole two people at least a few years
ago like there was definitely a writer's
room and stuff because I remember yeah I
don't think it's a typical TV show in
that way but it's so specific to them
that I don't think they could just peace
out and let it like they also do most of
the voices themselves and like yeah it's
so much work it's it's pretty dependent
on them from everything I have under
understand about you know I don't
obviously I don't know that I've never
met them don't know anything about the
inner workings Beyond what's been
publicly shown but that that documentary
that seven days to air thing from like
10. we go was one of the most
mind-blowing and exhausting shows I've
ever seen in my life like it's just
you're tired by the end of it just
watching how they're seven days unfold
it's like just every week is crunched
it's it's wild
um oh you know all I know is George
Lucas uh really hates them
it's all I'm aware of the list of people
that hate them I'm sure outnumbers the
like true at least in terms of like
Hollywood or or or celebrities or you
know they've tended to but the thing
that's so great about them is much like
you know SNL and it's Heyday and a lot
of the other kind of Staples of Comedy
they've always been very equal
opportunity they make fun of themselves
they make they're they they don't ever
seem to pick on any one particular group
you know they have a they have like
online philosophy politically sometimes
too like I would generally consider sure
and I feel like people would disagree
with me on this but I would generally
consider South Buck to be a liberal show
and it just hides that it's liberal
sometimes so people who are not liberal
don't realize they're watching something
that's making a liberal political
statement but there are some episodes
where it's like absolutely not or
somewhere like it it would head in the
right direction
well I mean the most brilliant of all
was their Obama election episode where
it's the next morning and all the hope
and change Obama Fanatics wake up
disillusioned that 24 hours into his
presidency
um The World Isn't actually really
fundamentally any different and it's not
as seismic of a shift of the world as
they're hoping for and then meanwhile
all the sort of uh apocalyptic if Obama
wins we're all gonna die Republicans are
waking up and discovering the world
didn't actually end like it was the most
amazing kind of down the middle take of
a way to be like let's maybe I'll try to
cool our Jets a little bit that like
it's not gonna be the Messiah it's also
not the Antichrist like
it's it's it's at best case or worst
case I guess is it's a bit of both just
another but it's actually really neither
to be honest
yeah which I guess is what they say
speaking of people stuck in things is
that is that it's not a Thai instrument
behind you Austin I was gonna make a
joke about how this episode is supposed
to be about
um Austin and something that he did but
instead he has been spearheading talking
about
there is there is there's a show there's
a show that you didn't surprise is that
is that instrument behind you is that
like it's not a xylophone is it it is a
Thai uh equivalent in a sense
or something can you play something on
it please
dance monkey come on
how cool is it's actually okay
this is a kind of shitty one
um but because like these low notes like
this one sounds right
like you can hear it rings for a while
but because I bought a kind of not great
one I hired a real musician who plays
this these bars are supposed to be
floating like you can see this one
actually is floating and it's not so
they're resting there's felt pads below
here but the whole thing is supposed to
be elevated so that it kind of wobbles
when you play it could you not just like
adjust the strings for that
I have tried pulling them as tight I
took them out actually Darren Corb was
over here and was helping me we were we
were pulling with all our might but it
really just needs to be mounted higher
but it's like a prefab like it came as a
kit that you assemble
um
from from Thailand it's very cool
looking what is it what's it called it's
very cool it's called A Renault Eck uh
there's two types of Red Knot which is
sort of like this family of of xylophone
or marimba-esque instruments that were
not tomb is the lower deeper one
um and they're typically played you
would play them like in octaves you know
that's kind of like uh sort of moving
around in in you know up and down like
together that sort of like
like that sort of there's a folk style
very specifically
built around that and obviously I've got
two different
um mallet
Styles the the slightly softer more
spongy mouth oh that's cool duller sound
and then a much more of a kind of
xylophone style that's why you had four
much brighter one
yeah there's two of each because you
need one in each hand there's actually
another one lurking Behind these boxes
that that's called a can which is
um like a hand organ
um uh it sounds a lot like an organ and
you think it sounds like a pan flute but
yeah
k-h-a-e-n and if you look on YouTube
someone playing the can it does not at
all sound like what you're expecting it
to sound like it is expected to sound
like a nice flute
it does not in any way
um it is crazy and they're also loud as
[ __ ] oh it's a lot bigger than I
expected
yes sir away from the camera yeah
uh Austin is in the foreground and it is
because I made the same I say made the
same mistake
no it's quite large you have to like
really hold that thing wow yeah it has
it has oh I'm sorry he's gonna have to
try it
again dance monkey dance
oh that's pretty big
can't hear you can't hear you can you
can it be done
I can't play this one's actually based
on the elephant on it I can't I can't it
doesn't make any sound because uh
there's there's air this has like a wax
sealer this is all these things are
basically handmade and so it's just sort
of like glued it's almost like tar but
it's more like Wax That kind of holds it
together and air leaks out of this one
so it just kind of sounds like can you
amplify it as well I don't know I hired
somebody who plays it professionally and
uh so mine became a wall decoration but
you see there's holes yeah here and you
so that's why you and there's two
because there's two sets of pipes you
can actually play like chords and stuff
with this thing
um and but yeah it's a really bright
sound yeah what would you say it sounds
like if not a flute it's an organ
literally like a reed organ
um like different from like a church
Cathedral organ you know a read organ
like you might hear in a smaller church
or even like in a funk band it sounds a
lot closer to that
um I also have a pair of woods which are
actually like pan flutes same same basic
color
um and the way they play these is
through these rapid wrist motions uh in
order because they they're basically the
same as the Peruvian yeah exactly but
it's just all kind of like a harmonica
in a circle but a completely different
shape um like a rotary hormone yeah you
can hear it a little bit on it's not the
loudest thing especially the people that
play it know the exact correct angle in
there again quite loud we had this
amazing musician named tantrical in
Bangkok that specialized in both of
these plus a bunch of others
and uh I bought them to mess around with
and to make like bad sound effects with
them
um that I could layer in for more weird
stuff process when you're writing for
international instruments are ones that
obviously instruments that are designed
around different kind of structures
musically different Traditions right
yeah what's is there just a lot of
research is it just a lot of kind of
getting yourself into the headspace or
so yeah so this one was really really a
unique
um
so they uh the showrunner is one of my
oldest friends I've known him 18 years
something like that uh maybe not quite
that much 16 17 years
and he first reached out
um that he and a kosho run over getting
this thing spun up early 2021 so a year
in
you know a half or more ago and they
hadn't started shooting and obviously a
year and a half ago we were like neck
deep in the pandemic still so they were
like we're gonna go to Thailand for six
months to film this thing
navigating pandemic like hardcore
Thailand quarantine procedures and stuff
is absolutely mind-blowing
um and
so he reached out and said you know
the whole differentiating force and we
haven't said the show is called Thai
cave rescue which is a whole there's a
whole topic I want to have about names
the whole subject I want to have with
you guys about names I don't love it
yeah that wasn't the name presumably
when it was shot I assume it was the
name and I assumed it was a working
title I assumed it was like a project
code name you know because it seemed
like it was it's called Thai cave rescue
and they were gonna later rename it you
know like I assume that was a platform
thing I assumed that was something that
was 100 Netflix uh decision yeah and
Netflix operates under the basis of you
know the analysis of their data you know
they're if Warner Brothers and and
Disney and and fox and well formerly FOX
NOW Disney
um and uh universities sorry if they're
all if they're all like movie companies
or or media companies Netflix is in a
way best thought of as a tech data
company that makes movies and television
shows
um and oh I'm not always leads to
excellent decisions that you like we
have lost Alana are you there Alana
I think she's stepping away for a second
because that looked conch that looked
intentional I was a conscience
anyway sorry continue
um
anyway so yeah the the
um yeah the title I I want to have a
whole conversation with you with you
both about about titles but I'll just
quickly finish up by saying that um
the yeah the the there's other
Productions obviously about this story
of of in 2018 when this soccer team of
boys got trapped in a cave in Thailand
and uh were trapped for almost three
weeks and a collaboration of somewhere
in the ballpark of ten thousand people
came together to rescue them
um it was a it was just a flood right
like they just went exploring and then
it flooded and they got stuck so these
caves are there's a million of these
caves and it's kind of like if you were
a kid growing up near Carlsbad Cavern it
would not be on a typical Saturday
afternoon for you and your buddies to
just go check out Carlsbad cab or if you
live near the Grand Canyon or something
like it's just local kids is a super
rural part they're just south of the
Myanmar border so it's like Way north of
you know Bangkok this big city center is
the southern end the very North is off
Rural and and you know there's no real
major cities there's reasonably big
towns and obviously it's like modern
Resorts big tourist area and things like
that but but um but the the Thai
population you know is living in pretty
rural conditions and so it's typical
like rural you would find anywhere in
the world where you know kids play
soccer they they kind of live their
their life in many ways kind of Outdoors
being outdoorsy kids so these caves are
a natural tie-in with that and because
uh monsoon season is a is a very real
thing and and very known to be very
dangerous there there's an elaborate
network of meteorologists and forest
rangers and people like that that keep
the population on guard what happened
here was one of these perfect storms of
these kids having a normal Saturday
going into the cave as normal kids would
and a freak unseasonably early
unseasonably early storm kind of catches
them off guard and the kids just happen
to be in there and the cave is so
gigantic it actually because they happen
to be in this particular cave is
probably the only reason they were able
to survive the whole thing because it's
so massively epically huge of a cave
that as it flooded it just kept pushing
them further and further and it's a cave
that goes into a mountain so it kind of
also gradually slopes up and so they
were able to kind of stay out of the
water but they still were
well everything you could think of was a
problem oxygen supply was a problem
obviously they were in there for nine
days before anyone even knew where they
were so they were basically on the verge
of starving to death uh they were so
weak and sort of delirious by the like
by the time they were found
um any any later and you know probably
some of them wouldn't have made it so
they all lived
anytime mate that is very much the focus
of the Ron Howard movie that just came
out 13 lives it it very much centers the
the UK diver cave divers that first
discover the boys and then the uh
I was gonna say they're Australian
aren't they
uh those actors what I'm trying to do
um uh one is British if I remember if
I'm if I'm not getting myself turned
around that tractor is definitely doing
an Australian accent that's not meant to
be British if it Colin Farrell
definitely was doing an Australian
accent
um but that's a different adaptation of
this than but this one is what I liked
about this was how much it was focused
on the local community well that was
yeah that's sort of the point I was
driving at is that like I think I think
that the Ron Howard film does
what one must do when trying to make it
to our movie out of a story that is a
genuine epic where there's you could
easily make a 10 hour
10 hour show out of this like ours is
six hours at six one hour episodes I
liken it to Chernobyl it's it is a high
production
dramatization but one which aspires to
is maximum amount of realism and
accuracy like it is meant so it's not a
documentary
um but everything in it is true which is
more or less how Chernobyl uh is is
framed as well like they both they both
have little areas where they need to
take Liberties for the sake of fitting
it into the format but by and large I
mean routinely like one of the most this
is like
slight spoiler not really I mean again
the whole story was international news
but the thing that makes it so amazing
is the stories and all the things that
didn't make the headlines that's what
the show like you said the local the
Thai Community you know 10 000 people
work together about 50 of them were
non-tie like the Australians the
American uh US military that showed up
to help that kind of thing it's
overwhelmingly driven by Thai volunteers
Thai Navy Seals the Thai government uh
like the governor narongsak who's the
the who was the governor of the Chiang
Rai region who had to kind of become the
the ad hoc leader of the operation like
all those people the meteorologists in
Bangkok and like overwhelmingly a Thai
effort it's like they're moon landing I
mean it's like the thing that is the if
you talk to like when we would we went
to record we went to these Buddhist
temples to record Monks chanting and we
were saying you know we're not here to
prompt a recording session can we just
record you as you do your normal
Services you could call it which they
would do every evening you know these
hour-long meditations singing singing
essentially one note continuously for an
hour
um and they were very open and welcoming
but when we told them this is for
a a retelling of the rescue of the boys
and the Tom luong cave it was like oh
please it's our honor because it's like
it's the singer it's like the most
unifying story for Thai people that you
can imagine it's it's the most heroic
thing and then the story and the show
it's all in Thai and as a as a as a PSA
the show will at least in the U.S
default to the English overdub that none
of them that's how I watched it to me
too I changed it yeah to me it was kind
of was I had the on-wall working so I
had to have it in English but yeah some
of the choices yeah well it's just yeah
today dub the um English speakers yes
yes even even the people who spoke
English are redone
um which is it's just like it's not
right because I was I thought they were
terrible like the English speakers
you know not to discredit like the dub
actors I know that's a whole profession
it's just not the same as on set you
know meeting the real people who you're
in the original in the original are the
English speaking characters people speak
what they speak in the show so the Thai
people speak Thai the Australians speak
English the Thai people speak English
when speaking to the Australians the US
military speak English
um and everybody and and the show they
made a big deal Thailand has a lot of
regional accents that are very
noticeable to the Thai people in the
same way that like someone from Alabama
doesn't sound like someone from Boston
that kind of thing like there's real
noticeable difference that have
undertones of you know religious
traditions and and class and like
anywhere in the world and the show is
you know they were very into I mean the
majority of the crew were Thai directors
you know like the whole point was to
censor the Thai perspective it looks
like it is
100 in Thailand all the at the cave they
got special permission to shoot at the
actual cave and then they rebuilt the
Interiors of it on a stage so that they
could do their diving sequences in in a
obviously far safer and and more and not
just safer but like you can actually
film when you can pull away walls and
blah blah blah you need to be yeah but
we had to flood the cave again just to
fill
it's a hell of a risk isn't it yeah
when I was there last week we got they
took us into a to the cave to show us
and and and
um and we kept joking that like this is
the beginnings of the sequel
um rescue the crew who made the show sir
how did you how did you get involved
Austin
the showrunner Michael Gunn is someone
I've known for a million years I'm I
scored a student film 17 years ago or
something that played in a little
festival and he was an intern at HBO uh
uh he he ended up he started as an
intern on The Newsroom and made his way
all the way up to being essentially
Aaron sorkin's Protege like and and
launched his career in Hollywood as a
result he's ended up riding for Black
Sails and a whole ton of other TV shows
and we did some little student era like
he reached out to me it's like hey I
really love the score in this short film
I saw
um and you know you want to get together
and just have dinner and then it became
really close friends for many many years
and then always you know working on
stuff and plotting schemes and and uh
for years and years we've been talking
about an idea for a musical like 10 plus
years we've had this idea that we always
sort of are threatening each other to
force the other to finally pull the
trigger on and
then yeah he called and this thing got
green that he had a pitched uh he and
his his uh co-showrunner Dana Ledoux
Miller who's a kind of uh uh half Samoan
half it's like American by way of Samoan
by way of French I can't even remember
the specific genealogy so if she she
won't watch this but if she were too my
apologies on on getting it wrong but
both of them shared this passion for
um pitching the show to Netflix as let's
do this very tie forward
um like let's make it because that it
really fundamentally is their story
anyway just because the the glory got a
little bit
um
disproportionately bestowed
and I say disproportionately with a big
asterisk because there's no doubt that
those Australian divers were [ __ ]
Heroes
um they just weren't the be-all end all
of the story and they said there's so
much more to tell not to mention just
getting to know these boys and their
parents like yeah spent so much time
with the parents outside the cave and
just watching the misery and the way
that they hold each other up and they
they help each other through this thing
that is uniquely Theirs to experience
like there's no angle quite like oh the
whole world is watching as our kids
might die and we just have to watch we
can't help uh another question so I was
watching
um I noticed you co you you share the
credit right in terms of Music how does
that work for you because I don't I
don't know of many soundtracks you've
worked collaboratively interested in
that I don't know what's that like and
how does that break down how does that
work the reason for that was that when
Michael first called me a year and a
half ago
first thing out of his mouth was just so
you know like in our pitch from a
production standpoint like all the all
the actors are Thai actors in fact the
boys who play the 12 wild boars 11 of
them had never acted before they're all
from that area they're always just like
they just literally guess that
oh because they're amazing they're
acting for a bunch of kids only one of
them who had any acting experience I
think it had done like some TV
commercials or something in Thailand I
actually can't remember what his acting
experience is
um but the rest are all non-actors and
cast from the area so they like they all
know each other and the crazy thing is
there's a moment in episode one
where one of the kids named bunam
they're a big soccer team you know and
so one of them is having a birthday all
this is true every part of this story is
is accurate to what was happening one of
the kids who goes by the nickname Knight
uh was having a birthday party and they
were just gonna go they finished their
soccer practice and then they were gonna
go [ __ ] around in the cave for fun and
then pretty much the whole team was
gonna go reconvene at night's parents
house for his birthday party and so
um one of the kids goes my mom told me
to go home I'll just I'm gonna skip the
cave but I'll see you at the party that
kid's name is bunam and so when he shows
up at the party and none of the other
kids are there the parents go where is
everyone they assumed that they would
all have been there by then and they're
used to again rural family they're used
to the kids being off for hours and then
making their way back home and that's
not inherently scary
um it's starting to pour rain so they're
a little bit like
no concern but these kids are you know
they're like Street Smart like like the
rural version of they're like they've
been out in the rain you know like yeah
like these are kids that are that's
nothing to think about like the way like
American Suburban families might freak
out over something you know that
innocuous this is perfectly normal life
these kids really can handle themselves
but it's getting to be like hours and
hours that they're late for the party
and when this kid shows up they're like
where the hell is everybody and he goes
oh I guess they're still the cave she
doesn't think anything of it of course
the parents know that these caves flood
immediately uh that's a known thing like
you don't and normally they just close
them during monsoon season like the
Rangers block them off and say can't go
in there until
a few months from now when monsoon
season stops but because this storm
popped up early and was unusually severe
the parents kind of immediately realized
the implications of this and immediately
rushed to the cave to see
if their kids are are there and in fact
they see all their bikes you know out
front abandoned and they can't they
can't get in the cave so so this boy was
kind of like the canary in the coal mine
who who shows up and and and gave them a
clue about where to even look because
the parents the kids you know they're
just like I'll see you when I come home
if they go you know hang out at a mall
or if they go explore a cave the parents
don't regulate that like crazy for
dinner the amount of things required for
this to go right obviously the
circumstances required for it to go
wrong are pretty extreme but the amount
of things required for it to go right a
more extreme like that one is not going
in the cave probably led to them finding
them much much sooner which gave them
increases they're all the survival a
significant amount 100 it's because it
took nine days yeah the kids were barely
alive when they found them
um and you know an extra day could have
been the difference
um and if if no one had thought to check
out the caves
you know that would have been that would
have been I wonder if there's also a
component to like I don't know if the
show gets to this because I'm not far
through enough yet I've only seen two
episodes
um if there's a component to them being
a soccer team meaning that 100 better at
working together like they already have
teamwork as a basis they know who the
leader is it does I think that's super
interesting because that probably helped
them and their Fitness the fact that
they're all like young and in pretty
Prime Health to survive that amount of
time without food but to your point
about
um if things had been even marginally
different that their coach is sort of
the the real sort of true true hero like
he's like a national celebrity in
Thailand because
they're first off he he saw all these
boys as effectively younger brothers you
know like he he looked after them he was
in his mid-20s they're all between the
ages of 11 and and 15 or 16. so they're
young you know like mid-range teenagers
at the oldest and he was about 10 years
older than that so he saw them as kind
of like little brothers
um and but he had lost both his parents
and his own brother and had lived in a
like because uh it's a it's a reasonably
common uh kind of grieving rite of
passage in Thailand if you lose someone
to go stay with Buddhist monks in a
monastery and they teach you meditation
and they teach you how to kind of Center
yourself as part of the grieving process
and so coach Eck had spent considerable
amount of time because he was basically
orphaned as a as a like as a teenager
and um so meditation practice was core
to his
uh being his his way of life and so when
they got trapped in the cave one of the
first things he did is start teaching
the kids to meditate and to calm
themselves down and had he not done that
not only would they have probably
freaked out and accidentally killed
themselves or at least one of them like
try to swim out in a panic and drown
themselves or or whatever but they also
they they went through their oxygen at a
fraction of the speed because of being
calm and and gathered he also had the
insight to
uh teach them to drink water as it
dripped from the ceiling
um uh like he was like you know there's
no food but drink as much water as you
can manage and so that kept them alive
you know like he had survival instincts
that were very well grounded and he kept
them together and he kept them and he
organizes them into a team kind of
rotations to try to start looking for
ways to maybe dig out of the cave of
course it doesn't it doesn't yield
successful results uh uh but it's like
to to to to apply structure I mean
imagine being stuck in you have a few
flashlights but flashlight's
notwithstanding you're in Pitch Black
reasonably cold air with the sound of
water forever for nine days yeah
um I mean it's it's hard to imagine the
the how they all didn't go insane
um is is a feat in its own right so yeah
his being there was um foreign a
complete dumb luck like the fact that of
all the kids to have potentially gotten
stuck there because again it could have
been any number of different folks to
get stuck there and so yeah it's truly
and to answer your question that I
unintentionally say was about the about
the music
yeah I know uh I'm just it's one of
those things where I it's called yours
it is among the best things I've ever
worked on like it is it is a truly the
number of times that I was just in tears
just literally sitting here writing the
music was nearly daily like it affected
me
profoundly and I I I haven't even
touched this trip to Bangkok last week
and getting to meet the the boy the real
boys the real Coach heck all of his
complete Insanity so
um
the uh um
what does it say was uh Michael the
showrunner first thing he called you
know he explained we're going to be
going to Thailand it's going to be in
Thai
um you know we're working real with Thai
directors and uh you know like local
Thai crew at least at least one of the
editors was in Thailand all the like
onset crew you know sound recordists and
and what there's a few key positions
that they they found people uh that you
know they like their their DP and people
like that they kind of gathered from a
few different spots but the goal was you
know if you can fill it with someone
tied do so and certainly with the cast
and
um
so
like I said you know
um you know obviously I know that you
commit
to uh whatever you work on as hard as
as theoretically I I would like to
believe as hard as anybody could
um and that it's never about the kind of
superficial like the Classic Hollywood
Trope with when when it comes to
so-called ethnic music and even that
term is a really shitty like it's like
there's this sort of default non-ethnic
version of music and then exotic you
know exploration Into the Wilderness is
the is the adventure if you disabuse
yourself of that extremely eurocentric
uh way of thinking
um
uh this has become this has been a real
passion of mine to just say rather than
go the Hollywood cliche of okay I'm
gonna write straight ahead you know
orchestral music or whatever and then we
sprinkle a few novel sounds on top
that's Hollywood's done that for a long
time when in the Earl in the in the
earliest incarnations that was its own
Innovation right that was something
really unique and profound and
interesting and represented
uh the important First Steps but we but
we live in a world now where it's been
shown repeatedly the most high profile
example of this would be like uh
ludwigorn since Oscar winning score to
Black Panther where he went to Senegal
he bought a one-way ticket to Senegal
and didn't know when he was coming home
he toured around with Bob Amal recording
Senegalese musicians studying on a daily
basis with them
like he was and then only later after he
had wrapped his head around all of their
musical traditions and kind of absorbed
that did he then start thinking okay
it's also a Marvel superhero show it
could it could benefit from some you
know some muscular Marvel Orchestra and
all that but it started from this
deeply rooted African perspective and he
features all these African musicians and
he really showed on on a mainstream
project that that you can't do the
sort of tokenized soloist on top of the
otherwise generically Western thing if
you're trying to genuinely evoke that
culture there's nothing wrong with
adding a novel instrument on top of the
orchestra if that's the if that's the
premise of the thing but if the goal is
oh I want to sound Japanese or Chinese
or Senegalese or Egyptian or these all
mean very specific things and there are
people that actually understand the
difference and this is like when I did
the path list you know I worked with
these two Bond musicians and all the
throat singers and it was a similar
thing of like doing the research and
also like letting them kind of guide the
process but this was on a whole other
level so Michael basically prefaced by
saying I already know that this is a
thing you're super passionate about you
care about
and that you will go all in on
um but there's a very high premium being
put behind the scenes on making sure
that this truly as authentic as possible
and I said him well look I would always
be the first to admit if I don't think
I'm the right person for a job for any
for musical or non-musical reasons I
said however in this case
um
for the last 10 12 years my right hand
uh in the job title known as
orchestrator which is
it means different things for different
composers but the orchestrator like
you'll see it in the credits for
everyone from John Williams to to Hans
Zimmer to every there's no composer that
doesn't utilize someone but they do
different things depending on on what
the role is what does yours do
um in my case
so the orc so like in the the
traditional role in the case of someone
like John Williams who absolutely knows
how to write for the orchestra better
than John Williams has forgotten more
about the orchestra than most people
will ever learn like he he so when he
writes music
um the orchestrator is not actually
saying oh this note can go to violin
that note can go to flute that note can
do they are
they are using their knowledge of
orchestration to
reformat into proper uh orchestral
recordings what we call a conductor
score format what he does in a shorthand
sketch so it to to to speed up the
writing process John Williams and
composers of that
you know Allen's of S3 James Horner
Jerry Goldsmith that that era that sort
of more generationally you know not
quite the current crop a little bit more
old school would right by hand on you
know on like a sketch pad you know like
this like a bigger paper than this but
the idea being that it's
four or five lines where you're like
okay this is this part's gonna be violin
and you can make a little sketch that
says
um actually we want first violins up the
octave second violence down you know in
octaves from each other that kind of
whatever little thing and some people
are like John Williams who look at it
and it's like studying a blueprint to a
fighter jet it's like he loads so much
information into that thing that you're
like the orchestrator is just there to
translate this in the case of some other
composers they maybe aren't as
comfortable with the orchestra they
maybe come from the background of like
being a rock musician or a record
producer or or jazz musician or whatever
um or maybe they're just not as
experienced with working with real
orchestras so they'll play things into
their midi sequencer or whatever and the
orchestrator has to come and go okay
well you know
this flute line was not acoustically
possible that low have you considered if
we try this or and it becomes kind of
like someone to help you optimize your
results I I have a pretty classical
background so my orchestrator is a lot
closer to the John Williams model and
it's this woman named Susie cider who I
started working with
um
uh like 12 years ago I mean she's we
started working together on journey in
the case of Journey I did all of the
orchestration myself
um but I needed someone to help me
prepare the sheet music and it was our
first we had just met so I said will you
will you um it's not like an assistant
that would be very dismissive it's like
um almost like a second unit director
um it's kind of more like the
relationship between a director and a DP
uh yeah uh like that's it DP probably
has has more power than an orchestrator
does in terms of influence of the final
product but it's like a senior level
position uh now there are some composers
that rely on their assistance for it and
they hire assistants who have
orchestration chops
um but the top orchestrators you know
like the folks you know a guy like Pete
Anthony for example who's orchestrated
for Danny Elfman not any number of
people these are
very highly paid very in demand very
sought after they often conduct the
session there's a whole you know the
Hans Zimmer types who are not very
classically trained typically are in the
booth and not conducting so the
orchestrator is often also the one
conducting
um there's a guy named Tim Williams who
who's done that for years with uh Tyler
Bates so you watch like Guardians of the
Galaxy or 300 or whatever those are
music by Tyler Bates and you'll often
see orchestrated and conducted by Tim
Williams like that's a common thing
um I tend to conduct my own scores uh
and so Susie was always in the booth for
me but we've I mean we've traveled to
London we've traveled to Nashville we've
recorded in La we've been through a lot
of life like one of my closest friends
deeply trusted you know I have routinely
paid her more than I am being paid
myself on a project just because
like the product benefits from having my
my crew at at their best and she's one
of the single most important members of
my crew she also happens to be Ty
um and so I called Michael and I said
you know I'm not interested in sort of
tokenizing a random person uh to tick a
box I don't want to placate it like I
would just as soon say let let a Thai
composer yeah take over if you know like
never mind the fact that I really
passionately care about doing the
research but if it's just if the
consensus is that that's that would
never be enough
um I'd be the first to step aside if it
seemed like that was the best thing for
the project and as just as a believer in
him and wanting to support his career as
one of my closest friends I said but in
this case funny enough one of my closest
collaborators is Ty she's a fully
trained composer she never mind our
collaboration she's also an insanely
experienced conductor you know like you
remember the concert tour of the Zelda
Twilight of the Goddess she and her
husband created that show and she
conducted like the majority of those
comments I've probably seen of it um may
very well have at some point they handed
it off to someone else so depending on
when you saw it
um but she also there was a 26. there
was a show called Pokemon symphonic
Evolutions that she conducted I think
every single one of like you know all
around the world she's I think she said
she's conducted the Sydney Opera House
eight times like she's been all over the
world she was she went on tour with
Evanescence as the orchestral conductor
of an of like a two-year tour with with
her and
um she's a badass she did that with a
six-month-old child too she would
literally breastfeed in the tour van and
then go out on stage that's very
Evanescence
yeah it was it was um um so yeah it's a
lot of it it's a collaboration you
already knew very well then it wasn't
that was I said what if I said what if
she and I did this together because she
she grew up in a Thai Community she lost
her brothers growing up and did the like
go live in a monastery like there's a
lot of real obvious connections
so we but we also we took time music
classes together because we were brought
in so early we hired this musicologist
and there's a Thai music musicologist in
La that teaches time music at UCLA we
hired her to start recording instruments
for the score and to just start teaching
us some of the intricacies of the
traditions and she said well you know I
also do a class if you want to just show
up Thursday nights down at UCLA so we
went and took classes together for six
months and and um uh it was I I mean
look it's already been an hour here but
uh it I could go on and on and on and on
she was one of the most composers is the
point yes it'd be amazing if you would
like and then we hired somebody else and
then she introduced me to her friend
yeah it knows no it was amazing we were
able like she and her mother uh we got
them because of the whole kind of
parent-child dynamic as such a key Motif
in the show
there's a few like very traditional sort
of Thai prayers and things that we
recorded she and her mother doing in
unison that we use in the score and like
you know we both bought instruments and
recorded ourselves we we worked with
local instruments you know I I I flew to
Bangkok for a week this last March or
April
um
um uh I think it was April kind of a
blur but uh and Susie was here preparing
for our Orchestra recording sessions so
she kind of monitored on Zoom until four
in the morning or whatever each day
while I was in person in Thailand then
we went together to Bangkok this past
week and that's so cool it was a cool
thing to do Austin
it was it was truly amazing and we hired
all these great musicians in Bangkok
where I I told them look you know I'm
gonna like I've done a tremendous amount
of research on Thai musical Traditions
but
you you are of those Traditions so at
any moment like you I am hiring you as a
performer but I'm also hiring you as
as a trusted collaborator that yeah
every opportunity that you see for us to
push this farther or to just be more
representative and or or or like down
some Alleyway that's lesser known within
the all the intricacies of these
Traditions like speak up and so you know
there were there were so many times
where you know that we'd be playing one
instrument and and and and and noon Park
is is um was kind of the main sort of
like musical sort of co-producer and the
contractor who helped hire the musicians
and he's himself a brilliant engineer
and and composer in his own right it
plays um a bunch of these instruments
including a bunch of non-tie instruments
as well
um
you know there'd be times where he would
he would say you know you wrote this for
like the sa'u which is kind of their
version if you're familiar with the air
who it's sort of the classic Chinese
fiddle
um the Thai kind of play it every every
weekend oh I remember the funny thing
yeah
uh well you bow an air who but but uh
you could pluck it if you'd like yeah
but I like to do my own yeah no exactly
I I respect that completely
um I always Associated the air who
because I lived in Chinatown in New York
for a year and there were always air
hoop players in this in like the
Lafayette Street uh subway stations that
would play Air who and uh it's a classic
so the song is sort of uh the Thai
cousin it's not quite the same but
they're they they have a lot of
commonalities in how you play them and
how they're built it's a coconut shell
base with two strings that come up that
you then bow and and
um but there'd be moments where he'd say
you know look I know you wrote this as a
sa'u Melody but
um there's you know the the slightly
higher pitched kind of like soprano
cousin to the so it was like the saduang
what if we try it on see if you like it
on this and then it was like okay yeah
that color fits the the environment
really nicely and then he'd say now you
know
um this takes place in Chiang Rai which
is part of the historically What's
called the Lana territory like the most
northern part but yes
um in contrast to um
how terrible being the larger have been
on this episode we are just extremely
disrespected we are awful just fully
focused being disrespectful the amazing
amount of work Austin
yeah let's hold the uh to hold the fort
and keep this earnestly play watch
listen and not the that's true Justin
talks about Thailand uh [ __ ] should
I ask a question real quick did you uh
work on recall
the Microsoft yeah I didn't because he
did her husband wrote the score to that
game there you go it's in her IMDb
credits and I was and right above abzu
and I was like did Austin do recore and
I just didn't know about that she's on
the the credit card yeah Susie yeah she
conducted that actually that was uh I
think that was
what year 2016 is it right back to absu
yeah we went to London to record uh for
abzu and she stayed because they booked
the orchestra sessions for recore right
after that so she just hung out I
remember I remember leaving to come back
home and she stayed behind because her
husband was then arriving with his own
score that he had written uh for recore
that she Orchestra
as uh yeah probably a lot of music
preparation credits
yeah she there's a there's like a
handful of orchestrators that when
they're in a bind they they help each
other out they ask for help from one
another and Tim Davies I'm guessing was
the principal orchestrator on God of War
ascension which was scored by Tyler
Bates the guy that also did um guardians
of galaxy and stuff and I suspect
um because he's worked a ton with Sony
like Tim did all the uh the first three
God of Wars as well and Uncharted and
all these I think you did I may not have
done Uncharted we definitely worked on
God of War I go to war ascension it this
is I'm annoyed I just clicked on God of
War ascension on IMDb and it's got you
know right as David Jaffe Ariel Lawrence
um staws Troy Baker
why is he gonna be number one and also I
didn't even know he was in that game
I didn't either I it is safe to assume
if you're looking at video games IMDb
really later
when he doesn't play Kratos
he's just [ __ ] stupid face mocking me
on IMDb
IMDb does that sometimes where you'll
have like an indie movie where a famous
celebrity is in one scene and it's kind
of their star power but they're not
actually the lead of the movie you'll
always see them listed first just
because it it's like an SEO it would be
an SEO thing it was funny um and Thomas
was alone's budget is listed as like two
million dollars I think my mind I
remember right which is wonderful
probably likes doing this joke where any
voice actor um that vaguely sounds like
Troy which is a lot of them he goes oh
it's Troy Baker and we were playing
metal hellsinger the other day which is
fantastic by the way and I was like you
get to say it and he was like No And I
was like it is Troy Baker because he's
got an accent it doesn't totally sound
like Troy but it actually is him he
[ __ ] shows up everywhere so great
yeah so it's not on the show but I've
still heard him this week IMDb has a an
interesting tendency to massively over
inflate low budget projects and under
inflate High budget projects because the
studios are trying to maximize the
perception of their margins on the
really expensive things and to minimize
the perception of losses and then on the
cheap low budget Indies are trying to
look super cool like we had a real
budget we promise and like movies that
were made for a quarter million dollar
boot the ultimate bootstrap Indie are
listed as like 5 million you know I mean
it's it's orders of magnitude wrong
whatever is that the filmmakers or is
that IMDb being wrong so we've never
told either it would either be IMDb or
it's some publicist yeah I guess the it
must be automated
I definitely
spin like a fly on the wall I've been
like with a producer where they're like
on the phone with the marketing and
they're like yeah yeah just put three or
like it's definitely coming the call
comes from inside the house at least
some of the time yeah interesting um
because they're just trying to stay
competitive you know because it's just
so easy to ride off a film when you go
oh that was made for 300 Grand like it's
just there's just no way it can be good
like there's just like it's easy to
especially in the eyes of Hollywood
producer like the the the target
audience for those inflated deflated
numbers essentially fellow
producer types in the business you know
it the average audience member I think
doesn't care one way or the other or no
let's narrow where games a bit better
then because I don't I don't think
in most
I don't think I don't think definitely
there's like people who just play AAA
games but there's also I wouldn't say I
wouldn't say an indie game is like
thought of as lesser if it's like half a
million budget rather than three months
it helps yeah the Toby Fox kind of
situations of like
um do it all yourself is is uh endearing
and tends to tends to be a selling point
um I have to get back to work Austin did
you have any any closing comments I feel
like we could have spoken about this for
another two hours it is really good this
week I I really I I really highly
recommend it uh despite the slightly
clunky title it has uh it is and it and
it's no denigration to
uh 13 lives scored by a good friend of
mine Ben wallfish or the rescue scored
by another friend Dan Pemberton both
excellent composers both excellent I
actually haven't still haven't seen 13
lives I've heard it's it's it's quite
good it's just obviously very focused on
one particular facet of the story
um I do take pride in the fact that this
one
focuses it it tries to not focus on one
aspect of the story and it doesn't lose
focus in the process it actually tells a
pretty tight narrative from my I know
I'm only six episodes but yeah it's six
about 50 minute ish episodes so it's
just shy of six hours and it moves that
clip it's Charming just don't do the
dubbed version like me dude but yeah
watch it and tie if if uh if you can the
the actors are are so excellent both the
professional actors who play the various
adult characters and the non-actor
actors uh in the form of the boys
um and yeah going to screening it at our
Premiere in Bangkok was one of the best
experience I think I've ever had in my
life because every time a new actor
showed up they all were like cheering
each other on in the theater and stuff
and like these boys they were right all
12 of them were right in front of me uh
and the just like kind of vicariously
feeding off their energy of going
they've never acted and they're now in a
big theater and like there's there's one
actress in particular who goes by the
name Yaya I can't remember how to
pronounce her like actual name but her
nickname is Yaya she's like a massive
celebrity in Thailand she plays one of
the lead roles and she's
huge huge uh very successful actress and
model and and like personality host all
all the things and so you know it's like
there's people taking photos of her and
like all the kind of thing you would
expect uh for someone of her of her
level of celebrity and in like three
seats away from her are these boys that
have never acted and they're like much
higher billing in this thing and they're
not just watching themselves on screen
which is itself probably unfathomable
but they are shouldering the story of
one of the most significant
stories to come out of Thailand maybe
ever I mean it's just truly an
incredible it reflects them so
positively
um and just yeah to feed off of them
just like everything made them clap and
cheer and they were so wired and and and
every time you know someone knew would
show up and then in the credits it's
like all the people they got to know on
set like the cinematographer goes by
they're all like yeah like because they
got to know everybody and it was just
that's awesome just truly so affirming
you know
you don't get to experience often that
would have been just very cool fully
optimistic you know it's like one of
those just there was no it was it was
one of the most like purely positive
vibes
yeah and never mind the expansive
meeting the real boys that's the story
for another day but holy hell
um unbelievable so anyway I appreciate
you teeing up for me to monopolize this
episode you still got yourself talking
all right you still you still still
managed to fit in there that's you
somehow managed to mention every major
every single one of them every single
one of them you said I was great I'm
more like John Williams as well
Dan Pemberton and Ben fall ball uh
benwellfish are both of your country
Mike although Ben does live in LA but uh
yeah you they're both they are both the
exports of uh now his majesty is the
only major exports from the UK nowadays
is composers so that's uh just makes
sense so it is uh maybe the case I hope
they were paid in dollars not pounds
um alrighty everybody thank you for
watching another episode play watch this
and I'm gonna pay some video game right
now that's my good latest video game
Derek and that is also wintry he is a
video game and also Thai cave rescue
limited series on Netflix now composer
we'll see you next week
the dinosaur cameo